hallo leute ich jetzt wieder romina
willkommen zu einem neuen video hier auf
meinem kanal heute werden wir die
germany's germany's next topmodel
produkte testen und ihr fragt euch zu
recht wann ist aber dass für germany's
next topmodel produkte ich meine die
produkte die manchmal mehr manchmal
weniger deutlich beworben werden und
wenn ihr germany's next topmodel selber
schaut wisst ihr vielleicht was ich
meine es sind diese momente wo du dir
manchmal denkst warum es die jetzt alle
diesen joghurt und unterhaltet euch über
etwas total banal ist das etwa die
produktplatzierung die am anfang
markiert wurde
man weiß es nicht genau aber eigentlich
relativ deutlich hier hier bis 2017
venus mars oder hier in dieser staffel
fällt mir auf dass es auf dieser joghurt
ist in den letzten staffeln war es ganz
oft gillette irgendwelche beauty
produkte in den badezimmern da haben sie
sich auch mal ganz gern unterhalten oder
der opel mutter in dem sie dann
einsteigen damit sie zum job fahren ich
habe auch diesen kanal glaube ich noch
nie bei germany's next topmodel
gesprochen ich habe auf instagram falls
sie mir da nicht folgt hier einmal witte
nachholen und da habe ich james ex
topmodel bilder parodiert die letzten
staffeln habe ich nicht wirklich
verfolgt ich habe dann immer nur am ende
erfahren wer gewonnen hat und auf events
auf denen ich dann war da habe ich dann
mal die kandidaten gesehen und alle
anderen waren so kommt man das ist die
gewinnerin aus der letzten staffel oder
ob das ist die aus der staffel und dann
manchmal so hat toll ja scheiße hätte
ich mal geguckt dann hätte es mir jetzt
auch was bedeutet es geht aber nicht
darum was ich für ein germany's next
topmodel verband kann ich sagte ab
sofort ihren tieren es geht nicht darum
was ich jetzt für engine tm gntm immer
schwieriger mein gott
es geht es aber nicht um mich und wie
sehr ich gntm liebe sondern um die
produkte und einerseits gibt es diese
produktplatzierung wie ich gerade schon
gesagt habe und andererseits gibt es
jobs castings für jobs und gerade weil
ich so lange nicht geschaut hat und in
dieser staffel mal wieder mit dabei bin
ist mir aufgefallen dass diese jobs
eigentlich auch produktplatzierungen
sind also ja immer ja ich habe das
gefühl gehabt früher sofort keine ahnung
zehn jahren da waren das wirkliche jobs
jobs und dieses habe ich das gefühl dass
jeder job hat eine produktplatzierung
ist und sie den job bekommen oder das
casting gemacht wird um halt das produkt
zu bewerben das merkt man einfach daran
dass die firmen die diese jobs anbieten
sie ja auch so typische social media
brands sind sich diese influenza marken
wie ocean support beieinander musical
buddy aber schon marken die man oft auf
social media sieht jetzt habe ich euch
wahrscheinlich wieder ein viel zu langes
intro gegeben wir fangen an mit
invisible für invisible wurde auch ein
casting veranstaltet wo romina hat
sascha und soll ihn eingeladen wurden
und ich dachte das ganz ehrlich zu lean
ist wieder kriegen wird weiß soliden
falls es nicht es ist die absolute queen
es würde mich wundern wenn sie dieses
jahr nicht als james ex topmodel wird
nun ab ob ich gebe jetzt schon meine
wette ab und ich sage es so lienen wird
gewinn bei diesem casting mussten sie
sich mit däninnen wissen doppelt
produkten die haare stylen welchen look
ich ganz strange frank war von romina
also das mit dem haarreifen also dass
ich würd's halt nie so tragen und ich
muss auch sagen der hfg musste ich
einmal selber ausprobieren mein einziger
gedanke war das ist wieder modern das
ist wieder in klangmuster das ist die in
safari collection frage mich gerade
ausdehnen so besonders macht er hat auch
hier diese wellenform die man bei
invisible kennt ihr kennt ja
wahrscheinlich alle diese haargummis die
aus in dieser telefonleitungen diese
form sorgt dafür dass die haare weniger
berechnen und nicht zu druckstellen
entstehen
das hat so ein bisschen seventies weit
sehr dekorativ ich würd's nicht das
gefühl dass der so
oh ja da lässt sich hd lässt sich diesen
ein bisschen ich weiß nicht ob ich so
ein fan von diesem schuster binde ist
das jetzt schon bin ich irgendwie hinter
mode ist es jetzt wieder gut kann man
das wieder tragen zu hält mich irgendwie
an meine mutter kann ich mal sehen was
ich bezahlt habe what happens in safari
hier zehn euro sagt man wahrscheinlich
über also ich fand das zeit eigentlich
ganz süß hier sind auch die haarspangen
drin die romina sich in die haare
gemacht hat uns zu liegen die augen die
haargummis kann man ja gar nichts sagen
die sind ja wirklich einmalig
superklasse aber bei den haarspangen bin
ich noch nicht so ein großer fan
so sehen die aus die hat mal für mal
glatt ein placement machen sollen so wie
meine fingernägel aussehen es tut mir
leid für mich gut aber ein liebling ist
das wieder
man ist wieder machen also sage ich zu
den man knipst sie am ende noch fest
okay was muss es rein machen und jetzt
zu kleben
jetzt ist so lass mich von den
einfachsten sachen begeistern hat so ein
bisschen festival feeling ich musste
gerade lachen weil ich dieses haar bahn
gekauft habe und hier einfach das
gleiche haarband drin ist und haben fand
ich jetzt nicht mal so schön verlosen
auf instagram das ist halt dieses
haargummi war ich so etwas wie nat
erfolge bisschen chaotisch aber genau so
hatte ich das gefühl dass es bei denen
auch ein außer ich habe mir noch so ein
haken geholt weil meine freundin darauf
schwört seit dieses invisible mit einem
stoffdruck passt eigentlich gut meine
haarfarbe aber was habe ich denn für
alles ausgegeben ich habe fünf produkte
gekauft und 44 eur 75 ausgegeben also
schon glauben bisschen teurer als wenn
man jetzt sei sie operiert obwohl dieser
noch ein teuer wenn man fern davon ist
das ist doch cool ich war sie wie viel
geld man für haarschmuck ausgeben möchte
aber ich glaube wenn man mal ein tolles
aufregendes outfit machen möchte
wie fühlen festival lockt oder keine
ahnung was dann macht es sinn ich habe
irgendwie eine hassliebe für diesen
haarreif entwickelt ich finde den
eigentlich ganz gut so aber dieses
muster macht mich fertig könnt ihr ja
mal in die kommentare schreiben wir das
finde machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt die flakon nie box wenn ich
jetzt keine box mit soliden drauf haben
ich habe die gntm von den box bestellt
okay du bist schön komplimente fühlen
sich gut an oder
durch sie fühlen wir uns wertgeschätzt
stark und schön und deshalb sagen wir
das gleich nochmals du bist schön ist
kann nicht gleichermaßen play werden
hast du gehört du bist schön genau du
genau so wie du bist brauchst kein
schlangen haarreif dafür
du bist schön wie du bist hier ist sie
im power juli soll ihn jetzt hat sie ihr
gesicht für diese box gegeben ich mein
die sind noch am start ihrer karriere
kann man ja so sagen außer um ihn an die
war schon vorher in tänzerin
wie fällt die boxen kostet 20 euro dann
wollen wir doch mal schauen und schon
das ist eine normale boxeneinfahrt
beauty aha ich freue mich eigentlich mal
wenn ich diese verpackung finger
bekommen weil meine schwester oder sowas
schicke dann kann ich mir gut verpackt
dann ist hier unsere ausbeute es sind 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 produkte für 20 euro
das heißt zwei euro pro produktes ist
schon in ordnung ich glaube es ist aber
wirklich an eine junge zielgruppe
gerichtet es ist kein bashing was machen
möchte essen sagt ja selber sie richten
sich an eine junge zielgruppe und wenn
du mit 25 oder sonst benutzt und ich
sage es richtet sich an der junge
zielgruppe dann meine ich das nicht böse
gegen dich okay es ist der essens und
patrice box und wir wissen auch und
läuft kommt alles vom gleichen
hersteller weil essens patrice und blogs
wird alles von der gleichen marke
produziert wo wenigen produkte und
natürlich aus plattling effekt wenn
lipgloss sagen sie in plan bing effekt
haben also dass sie die lippen bisschen
größer machen sollen dann schmecken die
meistens nach menthol kühlen
das gefühl ich bin begeistert von diesem
lipgloss im inneren lippen brand setzte
sich so ein bisschen ab das ist jetzt
vielleicht auch daran dass ich zu viel
drauf gemacht hat aber hat ein gutes
gefühl und andere plan ging lipgloss und
ich ausprobiert habe die sind ein
bisschen unangenehm gewesen also die
haben schon fast gebrannt dann ist hier
noch der absolute puder klassiker von
essens drin all about matt sehr beliebt
tut was er soll mascara sind auf jeden
fall gut das ist eine große auswahl gibt
booster hot chili ex hier haben wir zum
thema es wird brennen paul anka lipstick
drei rippen produkte eine grundierung um
lidschatten aufzutragen also erstmal das
drauf machen dann hält der lidschatten
viel länger haben wir noch eine relativ
neutrale lidschatten palette und ein
kleiner und ein großer platz fan
geworden deswegen ist eine tolle farbe
willkommen beim einem beauty channel
sind ganz normaler beauty gute farbe
sehr neutral das können viele tragen ich
habe nicht das gefühl dass ich einen
krassen deal gemacht hab also man weiß
ganz genau was da für produkte drin sind
man kauft sie sich mit dem wissen sein
genau diese produkte drin
sorry die box hat einen gesamtwert von
40 euro und man bekommt sie für 1995 das
heißt da macht man schon einen echt
guten deal
ich frage mich gerade ob denn zu liegen
und die anderen auch was dann für diese
jobs bekommen das ist ja jetzt quasi zu
linst box meint ihr dass die genug dafür
bekommen also die müssten ja geld dafür
kriegen ich es ist ja ihr gesicht was
dann hier mit beworben wird ich hoffe
die bekommen eine faire bezahlung
das ist mein look leite das nächste
produkt machen müssen ist es war sehr
teuer
es war ein sehr teurer einkauf als
nächstes haben wir fertig falls wir mehr
war für black wings wissen wollt was
garten sehr gutes video dazu gemacht sie
spricht zurecht bei flatex über eine
abofalle latics funktioniert so dass du
ein abo abschließt und dann bezahlt in
diesem abo 50 euro
monat aber das ist ein guthaben und
dafür suchst du dir sporthosen aus oder
oberteile ich verstehe bei diesen abo
modell nur nicht es sind ja keine
lebensmittel das sind sporthosen und ich
frage mich wie viele sportklamotten
kümmern haben auch man wirklich ein abo
für sportklamotten durch diese krassen
angebote vermitteln sie aber das gefühl
dass man mir da viel spart wenn man das
abo abschließt und man wäre ja richtig
blöd wenn man es für den originalpreis
kauf ich war richtig blöd und hast du
den originalpreis gekauft für eine
sporthose habe ich 45 euro ausgegeben
und für so eine kurze leo 59 95 60 plus
75 sind 135 euro und weil ich nicht das
tolle abo-modell abgeschlossen habe
wollte ich aber nicht was ich ja lustig
finde sind diese handytaschen finster
wird sich dass sie auf jedem foto oder
auch sein handy drin haben ich finde das
sieht ein bisschen klobig auf bevor ich
sie anziehe
sagen wir mal was drin ist polyester und
elasthan designed in california mexiko
ich bin fan von sport und letzte super
sporthose und man muss gar kein abo
abschließen sondern holt sich einfach so
nötig sporthose ich habe gar nicht
darüber gesprochen was aufgetaucht ist
mein gott dass man gleich richtig
zitiert an und an siemens
willkommen beim einer tablette leggings
review ich finde die qualität sehr gut
ich würde die verarbeitung auch gut ich
weiß ja natürlich nicht wie sie zum
waschen aussieht das müsste ich euch
dann auf instagram irgendwann mal sagen
sie sitzt wirklich schön sie hat ihren
guten bund diese super tolle funktion in
der ich ja mein handy hier rein machen
kann wie toll ist sie schon toll
es sieht beschissen aus das kann man
sagen also wenn man so nennen die an der
seite hängen hat aber wenn man sport
macht es ja eh nicht so richtig dass
contest lasst euch nicht von einer
klangschale ablenken
ja doch ich möchte sie eigentlich hätten
aber tue ich nicht ich finde sie sehr
praktisch
ich finde man kann sich darin gut
bewegen der stoff fühlt sich auch nicht
so wie plastik an der sprung teste ich
bin fan bin aber nicht fern von diesem
abo modell
ich glaube die mama von sascha auf dich
ich hätte ab sofort immer beziehe wenn
es um klamotten qualität geht sie war
glaube ich nicht ganz so ein fan von der
verarbeitung bei nicht allen sachen aber
könne die verarbeitung sieht ordentlich
aus also ich hab jetzt nicht das gefühl
dass irgendwas locker ist oder nicht
richtig gut zugenäht ist und damit
behalte ich die hose nummer zwei für 60
euro
positiv zu erwähnen diese tüte ist ein
bisschen umweltfreundlicher als formales
plastik aber die andere nicht oder was
würden sie beide nicht in dieses klassik
rennen gemacht made in lesotho leute ich
weiß ich war durch diese in wilstorf
diesen wildlife animal print film und
dann dachte ich ja gut obwohl ich mir
noch diese hose fans eigentlich
praktisch im sommer wenn man so ein ganz
großes oversize t shirt trägt und dann
halt darunter auf der sicheren seite ist
in dem man so eine hose trägt lässt so
doors in südafrika ich kann dazu nichts
sagen ich weiß nicht wie die
arbeitsbedigungen serien mexiko ich bin
dort komplett uninformiert könnt ihr
gerne was in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr mehr dazu wissen jetzt ziehen
wir einmal die hose an der spiegel wird
uns die wahrheit verraten
so würde ich natürlich niemals tragen
ich finde das sieht ein bisschen sehr
nach keine ahnung aus diese hose seid
ehrlich ich habe gut gegessen den
letzten wochen aber ich finde sie cool
scheiß ich finde gut finden sie sitzt
negativ weil sie halt hier nicht so rein
quetscht relativ locker unterwegs ist
und wenn ich jetzt so ein schönes großes
übertrage dann ist das völlig in ordnung
so also das ist okay bin ja hier auch
ehrlich über die produkte zu sprechen
ich finde diese leoparden hose super ich
finde auch die sporthose super der preis
ist ein bisschen habe ich 60 euro für
diese kurze hose das kann sich halt kaum
jemand leisten ich hab auch total
bauchschmerzen gab das bestellt habe im
abo modell wäre das natürlich super toll
und supergünstig alles bringt halt schon
die frage
warum kann man es aber so günstig
bekommen und wenn man es kauft dann ist
es so viel teurer da fragt man sich was
die hose am ende wert es gibt aber ja
ich sehe ich das leopard team auf jeden
fall im sommer tragen eine frage steht
noch offen warum habe ich rettig
überhaupt mit reingepackt weil sie immer
fertig sportsachen getragen ich wollte
ein bisschen rum stänkern aber kann ich
jetzt bei flatex nicht machen von mir
gibt's eigentlich ein relativ positives
ergebnis nur für die produkte also nicht
fürs abo modell das abo modell ist eine
katastrophe deswegen habe ich einfach
das video dazu anderen wisst ihr was ich
meine und unser nächstes produkt levi's
den lieber ist job gab es schon vor paar
wochen den natürlich wieder unser girl
colleen mit nach hause genommen hat hier
hat mir wieder mein herz geblutet denn
es war so teuer
wo man ja bei lieber ist sagt dass es ja
auch die qualität ist deswegen ist es ja
auch teuer und die hosen halten ein
leben lang ja ich weiß aber trotzdem tut
weh oh ich habe bei levi's 230 euro
ausgegeben
das ist das outfit was ich mir
ausgesucht habe wenn man auch das bild
geht dann kann man auch gleich den
produkten folgen und sie nach kaufen das
ist die heillos taylor dienst hab noch
nie ne levi's jeans besessen ich bin
gerade sehr stolz sie kostet sie 125
euro ich hab ja sonst keine probleme
ich gehe mal ganz kurz in die
zauberkugel ja dann kommen wir aus ich
weiß nicht was mit mir in diesem tag los
war aber die hose weil ich habe mir so
eine mühe gegeben beim bestellen ich
habe sogar meinen bauchumfang gemessen
um dann quasi die richtige größe zu
kaufen
ja und das kommt mir auch ein bisschen
groß vor also ich habe noch nie bei
einer bestellung so ins klo gegriffen
und sah spahn halten wirklich kein
bisschen deshalb finde ich eigentlich
noch ganz cool
das werde ich vielleicht sogar behalten
denn es ist ja wirklich ein cooles
outfit aber es ist so
pauli statt 230 euro aber ich glaube die
sachen könnte ich auch gut im secondhand
finden
sprechen wir mal über die qualität von
levi's die qualität ist ja gut dafür
sind sie auch bekamen tiers zwar eine
schnur und hier auch gerade okay hier
sind ganz schön viele fäden die so rumpf
liegen die verarbeitung sie tatsächlich
ein bisschen lasch aus einem männchen
seiten aber lieber es ist doch bekannt
dafür dass sie eine gute qualität haben
und dann das hemd gekostet also dass
herr mit hut 80 euro gekostet euro das
top 20 die hose 125 ich weiß nicht wie
ich mich so vergreifen konnte in der
größe und mir noch nie passiert das hemd
werde ich glaube ich behalten bei dem
top bin ich mir nicht so sicher was auch
ein bisschen groß ist und ich mag das
nicht mehr ganz so locker liegt ja noch
ziemlich einfach ich bin eigentlich
relativ überzeugt von den produkten die
geborgen wurden lief es ist ja eine
tolle marke habe ich gar nichts gegen
fedex hat mich ehrlich gesagt überrascht
ich habe gedacht die produkte sind ein
bisschen trashiger weil dieses abo
modell einfach super und sympathisch ist
invisible also ehrlich gesagt dieser
haarreif der fliegt beim ersten windstoß
weg das design na ja dann bin ich
absolut kein fan führt für das deko
element würde ich es noch vielleicht
benutzt ja die haargummis dadurch sind
sie bekannt geworden dass es halt was
soll man da falsch machen kann und ich
fand die flakon die box auch echt ist
eigentlich was wir auf jeden fall zurück
schicken werde ist die hose ließ viel zu
groß und vielleicht das ganze lieber ins
outfit außer ich verliebte mich
vielleicht noch in dieses 80 euro hängen
ja heuer das wieder gefallen wenn ja
dann gibt mir bitte einen daumen nach
oben und schreibt ein nettes kommentar
das unterstützt meinen kanal und wir
brauchen in diesen harten zeiten
unterstützung hier sind zwei weitere
kanäle lausche wanne und mein gaming
channel wo auch ab und zu mal was kommt
hier könnt ihr mich abonnieren hier
diesen kanal diesem wunderbaren mal über
den kanal
hier ist noch das letzte video oder ein
anderes
ja auf jeden fall ist es auch mega
geiles video und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder ist der antenne und
tschüssi copski